It's.
Well you hear. A regular
washing day the petals.
Yeah this is a you know do
a young child now so i do.
Who are xing every few days nappies
and stuff as you can see i've got
a sheen here and peter's been dry
and ah you know of experimented with.
With peter washing machines but i was
never terribly happy with them because.
You couldn't walk away from it. You know
you were totally involved in a wash.
And you had to be there for the
entire duration of the work so.
With a 12 washing machine i can
just turn it on walk away.
When the washing is
finished. I just come back.
Take the washing the washing machine
strode into the pedal spin dry the pillows
been dry as great because. I
just peddle it up to speed.
Takes about 15 seconds people up to speed.
Then you just as it's been an hour so
it's the pedal spend hours actually there
with they the saving devices such as you
still doing yourself a lot easier than
having to ring at all hours
you know works really well.
And you've also got this
legs in the business.
Yeah well i've not peddling as
much as i used to having a family.
I find
that i can do all the shopping on the
bicycle so i tend to make use of a car
and now i've got a car
that runs on gas rather than petrol so it's
not as polluting as with most vehicles
that. I am relying on on
the car to do shopping
and stuff which i'm not getting
as much accessibility used to do.
What other things. If you pedal.
Here
and i'll show you some of the stuff later i
got as you can see this is a people spin
dryer and i'm the other side.
They've got a multi-purpose pedal machine
a high speed better machine it's
basically just a very clean
mounted check to a bench top
and that's this spin dry here by
the way it's about 35 to 1 gear
ratio.
So every time the pedals go round once
this pin dry goes around 30 35 times.
The the pedal the multi-speed the
multipurpose pair the machine i just told you
about it's got a 70 to 1 gear ratio so.
For every time that those go around once
in the check at the top spin 70 times.
That means they say
pedaling at the rate of.
A comfortable pedaling rate is probably
a hundred hundred twenty. P.m..
That means that things doing that.
Eighty eight thousand happy
im pretty good output.
It works really well.
Yes this is the the more the speed. Sorry.
The more the purpose i see said i miss you
know something about you can see it's
got 1 2 3 4 sets.
Chains on it so forth
that the gearing to the speeded up from
the federales all the way up to the
deserved apparat is at the top here.
So this is giving me a 70 to 1
gear ratios are saying before they
when i speed it up you can see it.
That's going it a hell of a speed now.
I reckon i can get a probably
about ten thousand revs if i try.
What sort of more forethought come out of
here sort of thing for years before this
is what i've got on here at the moment
is a. Is a juicer blender base.
So i can just with due to a
blender something on top of it
but underneath here is there
is a vertically mounted.
So i can put a check into take this
off. And put anything i like onto it.
Too because it's. With
a very clean manager.
You can get any say anything driven
by an electric motor let's say.
Hopefully with a motor burnt out so you can
have a good excuse to pull the pieces.
And you just keep at them
or you strip the motor down until
you just left with it drives.
And you just insert the driveshaft into
the check shaven instantly turned used to
be an electrical apparatus into
mechanically driven and this.
What about the rest for house. Well.
A lot of people seem to get the
idea when they hear about me
that i run everything with pedal power
but i don't i use pillow power mostly for
direct mechanical conversion like this is
eastern machines of the show. Jr.
Or my other power is just
battery based electricity.
Got a bettery bank that's charged
by solar panels hydro system
and a couple of small boats quinto bones.
How long ago since. Your
pain lectures we built.
G 20 years.
I think i would have saved many
many thousands of dollars.
And so do you develop
sort of prototypes here
but eventually they end up in
products that our company.
No i haven't done
that for a while i have developed a
few prototypes quite some time ago
but most of the research
and development with around companies
now are done by other people.
I tend to be full time involved
with that with writing stuff and
and communicating with with
with clients and stuff.
Yeah. I'm paid a peddles.
I was instrumental in a whole lot of things
in the mean of course lately with the
setting up were actually with the whole
concept behind the room but a company
that was my idea back
in the early eighties.
But before then i said a name
and film society in. You know.
Established the no news which you
probably know about a local rag.
And i was very instrumental in setting
up the what started off as being rainbow
info which is now become the
number neighbourhood centre. So.
Plus a lot of other things i
guess between in-between time
and.
Yeah.
I was travelling overseas for a number
of years i came back to australia in 71
72.
And then i heard down the grapevine
that there was a festival in the
offing in the nimbin area and i had a.
There's overseas i'd heard lots
about the woodstock festival
and some big festivals in europe and
stuff and i thought this would be great.
I wouldn't mind going to that festival.
So i kept my ears to the ground and
found out exactly when and where it was
and i think it was may 73 was when the
festival was held and i came up here
and. Had a really great time and decided
that this actually be the place
to live you know i travelled up
and down the east coast of australia actually
traveled throughout most of australia
and and with that with the idea of working
out where i'd really like to live
and once i'd been at the festival he had
decided this would be the place for me so.
I went away to sydney
for a few years to try
and earn a lot of money to buy some land
and set myself up. Didn't get very far.
Just the same
or stories the more you earn them fast
you spend i decided to come back.
Anyway after a couple of years
and and settled in here
and then soon as i got here i may start
getting myself involved in community
projects. When i was in
sydney i was involved with.
Down to a drop in centre in paddington.
And i did all sorts of things there
including showing films and stuff to people
and i brought some projector equipment
stuff over with me up to nimbin
and decided to start with
the set up a film club.
In the film society.
And i did that for quite some
time i was showing films.
Every way for for a couple of years.
And i found that there is very
poor communications in this area.
And there's people. You know there's
lots of music museums in this area.
Lots of people doing all sorts of
in the time. But most musicians.
And i always found that there was
eight and nothing happening at all.
Where everybody was doing their thing.
All at the same time you know
and it was always a great conflict
everybody wanted to get everything at once
and of course some people ended
up missing out. And you know.
And i thought oh this is crazy. We've got
to do something about this. So i set up.
The no news actually stead
of being the no newsletter
and i don't so as to drop off a letter
and just make the no news but that was
that it was just starting off
as just a few new sheets.
Giving information to people about
what's happening in the local area.
And again
that was something i did once a week every
week so since i got here i made myself
pretty busy you know doing
all these things but
that worked really well where we could had
a great following with an image and use.
And all people were a lot better informed
about who was doing what and when
and where and it was. I found there's
a lot less conflict as a result.
And everybody really liked it.
And then i went one step further and i
saw that i'd set up an office in town
and just make that information
of not go that the rainbow info.
And that i was involved in that
for a number of years as well.
All of this was pretty well unpaid.
And then the rainbow inso
started attracts some
government funding
and some of the government funding
attracted was neighborhood center funding
and so we ended up changing the
name into the name and information
and neighborhood center. Later
on i think the new information.
Pat pretty well got dropped off and now
it's become the no neighborhood center so.
There's a number of projects that
i guess no things in them and
that wouldn't have been there without if
they hadn't have been for me starting
those things of
that many years ago.
I've always had a desire
to be self-sufficient
and whenever that may mean.
I mean as you get older and wiser you
realize that there's only so much
that you can do and it's very hard.
I mean it's impossible
even to be self-sufficient
and have any kind of modern
technology around you you know.
I guess even in all sorts of other aspects
we do need social interaction with
people so i guess. The
concept of self-sufficiency.
Depending on what
but extent you want to take it if
you want to take it to the extreme.
I guess it's just a pie in the sky. I don't
think anybody can really achieve that.
But on the other hand we can be self-sufficient
to some extent you know we can own
veggies. And we can do is
what i'm doing at home
and what we're doing here is become
pretty well self-sufficient with our
requirements. You can catch
your own rainwater of course.
So there's all sorts of things
that you can do for yourself
that don't require a lot of effort
or sacrifice.
About.
12 years ago almost 10 living 12
years ago. I had the idea of.
Of setting up a company just an idea.
There's a friend of mine doing
market research in nimbin.
Which he was.
Funded to do that
and he invited me to join his
group to work on concepts of
setting up different
things to make people.
Less dependent on social security
and hopefully employed
in some degree rather.
And i then started working
on this idea i had and i put
that into into this guy
submission and in that at
that time i came up with the name
of the rain but our company.
A lot of the concept behind
it and even the logo for
that even design the logo for that stage.
Now i think you'll find that there's some
record somewhere of of those submissions.
But since then i'd spend last time
just talking to people there.
And going around. Actually
doing some work in that area.
I mean i've always been
interested in renewable energy.
Federal power is one of these areas
that i showed a lot of
interest in early on the face.
When i found was that when people spoke
about renewable energy systems very often.
Conveniently or otherwise. The idea of
human power was left out of the picture.
And i thought this should really
sort of make a point with that and
and try to demonstrate that you
meant there is actually something
that ought to be considered is
very worthwhile considering.
Particularly when you look at the
amount of time and money and effort
that people put into. In the fitness.
You know he's people buy expensive fitness
equipment to put into their own home.
That they complain about the cost of
their electricity bills and whatever.
They're they're spending a fortune on all
this labor saving equipment they've got
around the house and then
they have in order to try
and create time in order to spend time
with these fitness programs right.
And i thought this whole concept is really
crazy it's all introverted to something.
But we need to do you know what makes it
make a lot more sense is to have have the
equipment that that that does your work
and keeps you fit at the
same time you know so.
So instead of buying
things three times over.
You just just just spend all your
time in the one hit both being fit
and doing your chores.
And not having to complain about all
these electricity bills because you're
creating your own energy to do so.
Well i guess if if you're going to going
to spend a lot of time on fitness
projects. You might as well. This
tour worthwhile children the process.
It's just seemed to be.
Perfectly sensible you know i don't know
if other people see the kind of logic
that i've got the same so logical if
you're going to spend time doing it.
Doing you know some fitness project and
then you my this will use the energy
that you that you're generating
in this in this fitness.
Thing
that you're doing to do
it your at the same time.
Well my concept of the
rain that our company was.
Have a company first of all that
that employed people obviously.
But a company where the employees the
employees were the decision makers.
So i. I i like the idea of
having a company that was.
I guess a bit of a co-operative
in some sense. So that.
I didn't like the idea of having.
Pyramid structures where you've got one
central manager or managing director
or whatever. Passing down the
decisions all the way down the line
and all the work is sort of slaving away
and complaining about the whole structure
and not being able to
do anything about it.
I wanted to create a structure
that was was quite different.
Where all the decisions were.
Coming from from the grassroots up rather
than from the from the structure from the
top down.
Also wanted the company you know
the funds of the company to
come from those workers as well.
So and.
As a company got set up now as as it
develops. We had a meeting. I was.
You know as i've saying our go back to
the history bit a little bit more now.
First of all i had this
concept an enlightened.
There was a couple of people living
nearby who said why won't you just go
and do something about it. So we put in
$30 a cheap place and bought some gear
and started selling at local markets
under the banner of the rain
that our company the company wasn't
it wasn't an official company as yet.
They anyway that sort of spread the word.
A lot better than just talking about
it and then a few years later.
Actually it was. It's february of 87
that somebody else heard about it
and said look let's let's actually
get the ball rolling properly now
and call a public meeting. Meeting
was called in valley seven.
To manage those factory in the. The
no neighborhood center as it was and.
To.
See if we could get all the
expertise all together
and in the one place to
formalize the company properly.
So we had the meeting and we found
that all the required skills
row there at the meeting
and everybody's really
keen to go on with it.
So we actually decided to set up a company
and in of july 7. We had
the company registered.
And in august of 87 we
set up shop in nimbin
and since then we've never looked back.
I mean yeah we've just just
gone from good to bare
that you know.
Well to start with we were selling
mostly just reselling. You know just.
Which there are still
resellers here now that we've
but through through this time i guess our
products have been become a lot better
researched. To start with.
We had some of their own product not many
but just things like control boards.
We did make our own
regulators from million face.
We made their own rechargeable torches
right from the beginning. And then we.
Right at that meeting of
february 7 i told you about be.
Decided then that one of the products
that we really got a way to get up
and running was the the hydro.
Taught me of the idea of the
micro-hydro electric system.
So we put a lot of effort into
that to actually be able to come up
with a good product in the statue.
But it still took us almost a year before
we actually got our first first ones.
On the showroom floor
and ready for sale.
Well i've i guess i've
always been into making.
Things public you know as
with a company we don't like.
And we don't really endorse
the idea of copyright
and of patenting you know that's the stuff.
We tend not to patent anything here.
We just like. Things to be
public knowledge and and.
To be out in the public arena so to speak.
So.
As i said i've often been writing material
with the view of publishing a just to
make all this information
also public knowledge.
And we wanted to be able to produce
a catalog for the for their own
that our company just a show will
show people with the product
but we didn't wanted to just be a catalog.
We wanted it to be a lot more than that.
We wanted it to be a handbook you
know so that people could read it
and could learn from it themselves.
Of how to do all this stuff for themselves
without having to to employ some expert.
You know. To do all this stuff or.
You know the thing with.
Low voltage systems is
that you don't need to have have a
qualified person to install it for you.
Seriously anybody can install their own
level the system because there's really no
danger great danger involved.
The biggest danger
that you possibly may have is the
possibility of setting your house in fire
but if you do it properly and you
put fuses in your system and stuff
and it's not going to happen anyway so.
We thought oh this is a great opportunity
to do to keep the tower with the people.
And.
Just remind me of john
lennon song about it but.
You know the idea of have you know of
making the skills available to everybody.
So i started to write the
book with a view of it.
Starting off with a view of being
the rainbow tower company catalog
that i thought would be
a lot more than that.
So i wrote it in a way
that you don't need any fantastic skills
to understand it you know written in
layman's language so
that anybody with with.
Just the basics of primary school
education could understand the book
and with any kind of skills are
doing anything for themselves.
You know they should be able to
put up their own power system.
So that book was finally ready in.
I guess in that much the same time as
either system was was it shopfloor.
And immediately was a great success.
That was our first edition
when our 6 edition with in
the meantime we've sold.
13. Thousands of them. So.
And it was selling fast
and fastest and goes on.
So it's a it's turned out
to be a very popular book.
The company was. As you'd expect.
Of course when we first opened up shop in.
In august of 87 which we hardly making
enough money just to support one person.
But.
The word soon spread that we were there
and. The strange thing
with the figures but.
In the first year i think we made
a hundred thousand or something.
I think turned over.
But since then we've been growing at the
rate of 45 to 50 per cent per annum right
up until last year we slowed
down a bit in the last year
but it looks now actually that
we stand to take off again.
So it was a growth rate of
40 to 45 percent per annum.
For four years in an slowdown and
that looks like we're
probably going to go back up
that same growth rate which
makes it very difficult
that kind of growth rate because
it's like trying to run
when you've had to learn to crow.
You know and that's the way the
company has been going all along.
You know now we're
employing about 20 people.
We've got a turnover of well in excess
of a million dollars a year now
and i think that will probably hit
at least one half million this year.
And mr. growing we've set up another
company called reshape which is.
So reshape is our overseas marketing
company. And we say that.
We've. We predict
that reshape is going to really take
off in the next couple of years
and it reshape is going to far
exceed sales within australia.
At present. We're showing australia wide
but once once the overseas market
really starts to take off.
I think
that the sales in australia is only going
to be a drop in the bucket as compared
her sales overseas.
I can say we're going to go through
and number of really
huge growth spurts yet.
One of the problems with promoting
renewable energy in australia is
that people need to know about most
other people there in remote areas
and the greatest difficulty is marketing
and advertising to remote areas is
very easy to do to make it to a city
suburban environment but.
As it stands at the moment.
That's not where our our sales lie
ourselves you know i think for instance.
If you look at home states.
Cattle stations etc..
A lot of them are running on
very big diesel generators.
And in this day and age and
saying that they should rely.
For all their power on diesel fuel being
exported to transport all over the country
for them. And the same of
course is the same idea.
Holds true for. Countries
overseas you know. When.
When we have any kind of.
Overseas aid programs in invariably what
but they give to these people overseas
is diesel generators and to me.
It's totally insane. You know these people
can't afford to buy the days of foreign.
And usually what happens is i
mean it makes people feel good
that senator them you know maybe also
wonderful tax dodging all sorts of stuff
but it's no use to these people at all.
You know first of all they don't have the
mechanical skills to maintain you quick
meant. And secondly that you
know in small pacific islands
or remote areas southeast asia
wherever you're talking about.
It's just too expensive for them to get
a d or they just can't afford it. So.
We need to.
You know it's makes a lot more sense to
in these areas to have renewable energy
systems. You know once the system is
up and running it maintains itself.
You know you put a solar panel out
in the sun and you know it it all.
Have the capability of charging a
battery for the next 30 years and.
You know without doing anything too
if you don't there's no moving parts
and you don't have to maintain you think
there's nothing to fix anything you just
placed in the sun connect the
battery to it in a battery
or just keep on being
charged both right so.
So in remote areas of australia
and anywhere else in the world.
I guess it just makes so
much more sense to. To have.
Energy systems that that detect.